let me go crazy for you they really do  women women like he do you get hit on by  women uh yeah a little bit I'm a bit of  a flirt I found myself there's a thing  early in the book where I was at a party  with Jenny McCarthy and I she's so I  remember watching her on MTV and feeling  like wow if I really was gonna kind of  try to experiment on the other side she  would be someone who could that's a  woman if you're gonna go with a woman it  would be that reason like yeah the boobs  and she's very suggestive and so I found  myself trying to initiate some sort of a  three-way was she and Donnie Wahlberg  and halfway through I realized oh my god  I am too scared for this ever to have I  mean what am i doing and I just failed  you but yeah but yeah they ended up  together they did no they absolutely not  on my show your attempt to get a  three-way ended up with them getting  together yes well partly yes they've met  on my show and they celebrated their  anniversary on my show as well  you